t'as plus faim tu reprends pas des
coquillettes
non ça va merci mes respects des foules
peut-être encore un petit peu fort tu
veux au moins servi ça me fait tellement
plaisir de vous rendre service les
enfants moi j'étais tout seul pour vous
occuper de ce gros bébé aurait bien aimé
ça que ma mère elle me rendre service à
cette grippe bourges
alès combien de temps la juge pour ce
choix
[Musique]
avec ce boitaclous
meriem
savez vous pouvez vous servir de la
cuisine bon mon nom je ne sortais pas
déroger l'abandon
à bien mes rêves pourquoi vous faites
des trucs comme ça
désolé je voulais pas te faire peur tu
vas aller tgb t'utilises à ta mère de
partir là ça fait trois semaines qu'elle
est là trois semaines non je vais moins
bon c'est elle moi
aa
or veut
non non merci écoute moi je te parle un
peu on commence au fait à rentrer dans
une phase où on a besoin de l'espace de
construire à 2 tu comprends bien sûr
vous avez cassé avec emma ah non non non
non pas du tout pas du tout maman il
faut que tu partes maintenant mais je
suis ta mère tu as besoin de moi
ah non non j'ai pas besoin de toi en
fait je suis un adulte ou que les
comment tu tu sais même pas faire à
manger comment comment tu vas faire avec
ton bébé 1 tu vas laisser mourir de faim
c'est simple je sais très bien me faire
à bouffer tout seul tu tu m'emmerdes
lama mais ça va non mais t'as vu comment
tu me permets toi tu me parle pas comme
ça mais oui mais c'est juste que tu me
dis d'une traité comme si j'étais un
bébé cadum savent à quoi ça va oui ça va
je me casse ou de bêtes pas tout mais
non
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]